well you don't go out for commercials uh
I don't really go out for auditions
anymore uh depending why
I just don't care for right now
oh you gave up oh wow
I want to know why
different season right now yeah you know
what I know we talked about yes the last
time explained I I told it's not going
to make sense to you because I think
that no I wanna I I think this is gonna
help me I think your dreams of your
ideas of success are different like you
want
like I similar to David like I have this
thing where it's like I want to make
like quiet money yeah and I want to do
things with that quiet money I kind of
like there is something very taxing
about being like camera facing all the
time there's something very like
soul-wrenching about that experience and
I've never even done like you know a
hundredth of what you've done but so
yeah it's a weird place because I'm a
beggar right and Beggars can't be
choosers so like I completely understand
this so when when these roles do come in
like I'll just be I'll pick and choose
the ones that I really really care about
right which is why I haven't booked
anything because clearly I'm not in the
run-up for any of this stuff but at
least I get to audition for the things
that I enjoy even trying to care huh
yeah
so it's like you know and this is the
season that I'm in I mean it might
change later but I kind of I like being
as in the lowest rung of celebrity as
possible because you get to just not
exist for a majority of the time you
know you get to be who you are say what
you want and if people say hey I'm gonna
take this away from me I don't care I'm
a nobody who who cares and also it's
like if you were to ever hit or actually
reach your dream the likelihood of you
be you being still in that same week for
anybody is 99.9 and look let's just say
this right let's just say by God's grace
I booked something and it makes me
Millions right and they find something
out about me like I don't know I [__] on
somebody's [__] child okay and they
go you know what you're canceled I'm
like I don't care I made my money I'll
yeah I'm still gonna do the stuff on
YouTube and whatever else your
perception of me is completely fine it's
valid because what I put out there is
what I put out there right this is an
interesting thing you're saying I I've
had to rework in my mind you know what I
mean why I've been so depressed okay and
I think it's because you know I'm trying
to hold on to things right I'm afraid of
losing things and and that's where the
fear comes from but if I have no
attachment to those things I would be
free and I'm trying to live in a world
where it's like I'm fine doing what I'm
doing at the moment which is my loves
this bad friends and touring and stuff
right and they can never take those
things away right it's when my mind goes
you know when I see on Instagram oh you
know my friends are killing in the
movies why why not me and this and that
and that's where all my depression and
my anxieties and my you know low
self-esteem derived from but if I let go
of those things right then I'm living
you know I mean a free life what do you
have to do you think to let go I think
I'm getting there but do you think you
can Will yourself to let go because a
dream is a dream is a dream you've had
these dreams since you were younger I
think I think because of the fact that
it really doesn't do much even
financially for me
you know being a guest star on a TV show
or you know you know me and Andrew have
been on tour and we go to these cities
like in the Deep South and there's
thousands of people coming out right and
they love me and I love them and that's
all I wanted anyway you know I mean is
to go I'm talented I have something to
share with people and now white people I
mean from areas of the country that I
never thought would get me get me and I
get them and it's been a really cool
experience man and I was gonna say does
that still feel like it's not enough you
still feel like you need to go for more
I think I think that's enough and if I
can live in a world where that's enough
then I'm untouchable
you know my fears come from and my
depression and anxiety and my sadness
comes from losing these things that I
don't even have yet like oh now I can't
you know what I mean be in a huge movie
with these people who gives a [__] you
know it's like if I can just let go of
that I'm a free man and I'm working that
in my life right now
yeah man I mean look I'm I'm kind of in
uh I was gonna see is it too real I'm
sorry I know where no no I was gonna say
there's a there's like a Taoist
principle that says all is the word
Buddhist one of those it says all
suffering comes from desire or something
like that right where it's like if you
just kind of realize that you're good
with what you got then you won't be sad
about [__] you know what I'm saying
um I'm a little different from David in
terms of like I still definitely have a
lot of [__] that I want to do
um I still definitely have like I want
to do that [__] big movie and I want
to like star and some [__] like that
I've been telling them for like years
I'm like bro I'm writing a movie for us
I'm so sick of it
hey bro 70 done yeah and then the second
text in my head and I'm like don't
[__] talk to me yeah yeah
I'm testing is testing you blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah it's
meaningless yeah I have that all the
time yeah man it's done my treatment's
done like what treatment you have cancer
I mean like I don't want to hear it you
know what I mean oh my God wait am I
that person that's like yes I got a
movie for you and then oh no yeah that
guy now dude oh you're just Hollywood
steam oh my God I'm those meetings that
lead to nothing
all right Tim dude we're having some
crazy moments right now Tim just until
it's locked in yeah then you talk you're
right right it seems weird yeah 70
percent what does that even mean how do
you know the percentage how are you
doing yeah because also like I find that
if you announce something too soon
you're already getting the payoff like
internally of saying I'm doing this if
you just keep it contained in your body
and you keep it a secret and that it
fuels you into the work but the moment
you say hey I'm doing this you're
already rewarding yourself the feeling
of things you're doing that's so funny
you brought that up because okay so I
just recently got diagnosed with adult
ADHD right oh him too oh dude okay so
and someone someone told me that when
you announce things too early you're
giving yourself the dopamine that you
would normally get that you would need
to work yes when you get like that last
minute fuel to write some [__] so uh
yeah you're right let me stop
because he has ADHD he's gonna forget no
but no you're not gonna stop you're
gonna hit me up at 2 A.M in the morning
he's like bro 71 percent here's what
happens because literally every time I'm
laying in bed at 2AM I'm like oh that's
a good little couple lines for the
scripts I'll have it I'll put in my
phone I'm like dude you're gonna love
this yeah yeah I want to tell you about
it you know I get into those like idea
Vortex vortices in when I'm in the
shower of War time I think so I believe
it or tie four times four times
um but I get like I'm like I have a song
for this scene for this thing and I feel
it feels so good in my chest I'm like
I'm a [__] creative genius you know
and I want to announce it so bad and I
usually do and I tell my sister and then
now that I got the dopamine hit and then
I'll never think about that thought
again wow so interesting so what's the
point what's the uh you just stopped
doing it you get the high right it's an
addiction then it is it's interesting
it's it's an addiction of like almost
like just like sucking your own dick for
a second yes it's exactly that oh you
know what else is an addiction is
getting a job
yeah right so it's like I remember a
couple years ago when I did that movie
in Hungary I remember going who's in it
I'm I'm gonna be in it with them yeah
and that it was like a shot of [__]
ego opioids opioids Macaulay Culkin
talks about that a lot he does yeah I
think that's why like part of the reason
why like he quit acting like he was like
just being like a careerist like that
looking for your next hit all the time
but then when you're actually there you
go why am I so depressed that's such a
hard way to live though like yeah you're
constantly chasing this feeling that you
have to replenish in order for you to be
happy you're never happy and still yeah
you know that's [__] hard because I
Garden every morning just like my
happiness your Tomatoes yeah I garden
and that's like the happiest time of my
day when I'm just by the plants and I'm
[__] doing this [__] and I watch
these things grow you all
yeah oh man [__] yeah that's old man but
I could see that for you Bobby what I am
getting Garden getting into gardening
stardew Valley because he's already into
stardew Valley like hardcore [__]
Garden [__] I don't know I don't even
know what [__] vegetables I want to
grow oh really okay based on your
stardew Valley knowledge you know what
do you know about uh okay well you have
the soil what kind of soil put
fertilizer down okay right and then you
need well this is based on the game the
game is pretty exact let's line it up
with him all right so um I take a hoe
and I and I soil the ground right how do
you soil the ground what the hell you
stick in the ground
quick quick that is a very different
game
and then you put the seed down come on
the soil yeah and then you put
fertilizer down right then you water it
every day in the game and then you know
some vegetables they're all seasonal
right so it's you know this is like a
switch that's so [__] stupid what
you're playing a game so that you could
do in real life
what's up
look at that up man
let me show you my crops turn on the TV
but then you don't have to like get
dirty and stuff
he ruined his only joy in life dog
what are you doing it's [__] crazy
what's up bro this he grows one tomato
he thinks he's the [__] dog don't let
him ruin that for you bro I mean it's
like you're I'm not gonna go out buy
Farmland but you clearly have an
interest what is you haven't I don't
have no I don't have an interest in
farming I have an interest in grinding
oh what kind
in video games there's two types of
games there's games where you grind I
play a game called Elden ring right now
it's so much grinding it's like you just
have to harvest kill animals to get
their bones to make arrows so I'll spend
12 hours just killing animals repeatedly
repeatedly repeatedly it's called
grinding
and I when I'm like that when I do that
I don't think about my life I don't
think about my feelings I'm checking
terrible I know but that's I'm I know
what I'm doing when I'm doing it it's
coping I'm coping I would say like what
David is saying because like a lot of
gardening is grinding you have to check
in every single day you're doing very
similar things the thought process is
identical so I think you would actually
feel a little bit more I don't know like
love yourself a little bit more if you
had a tomato to harvest and be like you
know what I'm gonna I'm you know self
you know I'm sustainable like I am it's
not even that deep it's like do I play
this video game or I dishes
but you don't wash dishes in real life
you know what I mean like if you if you
just played a game where it was like you
shooting [__] you're like in a different
galaxy that makes sense to me because
it's [__] fun as hell but you're
planting vegetables in a game and this
is how shallow minded and ridiculous you
are right now
it's not just a farming game there's
mining but there's mining there's
fishing there's you you marry you have
kids
oh yeah because they have
caviar don't
have ever you'll never even play games
no wait David
um um put me on to this idea of getting
um fried chicken skin and putting caviar
on with some French
we did that on our podcast
yeah we could just go to like churches
or some anywhere Jollibee or and get
fried chicken skin so we we eat on our
podcast I like potatoes